hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
bleeding heart greenie millennial and opposite
of domestic goddess domestic demon like i just
haunt a specific part of the airport i
don't have a passport so i can't get out
and facebook can obviously tell because
they've been serving me zero co ads
i mean look at that branding
it's catnip for millennials
so obviously i bought the whole set i've
tried them all and i thought i'd review
them because i think it's a cool example of a
well thought out environmentally friendly system
most of the products are household products but
there are some beauty products in there as well
this isn't sponsored zero co offered to send me
products after i've reached out to them about
a question but i wanted to try them out over a
longer period of time without too much pressure
so the concept is zero co is a household
and personal care product company that
focuses on reducing single-use plastic and
i'm usually quite skeptical when it comes
to brands that focus on reducing single-use
plastic part of this is because i'm used to
reviewing skin care and compared to other
sources of single-use plastic in our lives
skincare is really just not that much it
takes a while to finish up most products
but a lot of skincare brands act like you're
going to save the world if you buy their serum
another big reason is that a lot of plastic free
brands make a lot of trade-offs that don't really
make a lot of sense they aren't really well
thought out and it ends up being greenwashing
for example sometimes they switch to really heavy
glass containers that end up having
a huge carbon cost for transport
and they also break a lot in transport which
means you end up wasting a lot of product
sometimes brands switch to bioplastics
that might be compostable but not truly
biodegradable they can't be recycled and
most people don't compost them properly so
they might have been better off
just using recyclable plastic
some of these bioplastics also
have a bigger carbon footprint
than traditional plastics if you
make them using renewable energy
and the final reason is that most eco-friendly
brands are also really into that whole clean
beauty scientists-are-trying-to-kill-you
thing i hate this sort of marketing i've
talked about why in my video clean beauty
is a scam and won't give us safer products
i don't really boycott this because it's
so hard to find brands that have zero clean
beauty fear-mongering in their marketing
a lot of the time it's because the brand
themselves are misled and i try to be nice to
people who are doing the wrong thing out of
good intentions but i do get really annoyed
and if there's an alternative i'll take it
but zero co do household products
which is something we use a lot more of so
we have a lot more single-use containers
and australia is pretty bad in terms of
the amount of single-use plastic per person
zero co also have a lot more dimension than just
taking ocean waste and turning it into bottles
i asked my two favorite sources for
environmental science questions what
they thought the eco well and waste-free phd and
they both said it looked like a pretty good idea
zero co is based on a closed-loop refill system
you buy their products which come in refillable
pouches there's also optional forever bottles
which come in pretty millennial friendly pastel
colors i bought the starter kit which has
everything in it you fill your dispensers
with the pouches once you collect 15
empty pouches you send them back in
the reply paid mailing bag you need 15 to
make the carbon cost of mailing worth it
zero co then clean and refill
the pouches for the next person
the dispensers are made from ocean beach and
landfill-bound waste there's a tracking code
on the back so you can see where your bottles
have come from for example all of mine have
come from indonesia the pouches are also made
from plastic that would have gone to landfill
they can be reused over and over and over for
a very long time according to zero co when
they've worn down they're going to be used to make
something else which zero co haven't disclosed yet
as well as being reusable these
pouches are a lot lighter than
traditional bottles and so that saves
the carbon emissions from transport
zero co has also recently introduced carbon
negative deliveries that means that offsetting
two kilograms of carbon dioxide per one kilogram
produced carbon offsetting is a bit of a mixed
bag a lot of the time it's used as an excuse
to not actually reduce emissions but i don't
think that's what's actually happening here
i think it's just meant to be a nice bonus
i'm sure it's not really a perfect system i
don't think using products is ever going to be
not using products at all but i prefer not
to live in filth and this seems to be a lot
better thought out than a lot of systems
i've seen and it covers a lot more bases
zero co also asks for suggestions if
you work in the environmental space
for how they can improve so that's also quite nice
on top of being pretty damn thorough the
things that really sold me on zero co
were firstly they're super
convenient and customer friendly
they have all the products i normally use and
more getting everything from the one place
is a lot more convenient and also has a smaller
impact than say getting laundry detergent from
one place and dishwashing tablets from another it
is mail order only though and the 15 pouch system
might be a bit of an issue if you're running low
on one thing before you run out of something else
but they are looking into getting
their products into stores soon
there are tons of clear instructions and answers
to questions they have a super comprehensive
website they have videos on rolling out the refill
pouches they have tips on things like removing the
tamper rings before refilling your bottles
which as an overthinker i really appreciate
they've also been really responsive to questions
through their chat and through their social media
the second big point is that their products
actually sound really good my biggest worry
whenever i switch to an eco-friendly brand
is that i don't end up liking the product so
i don't re-buy them that means that i don't
end up reusing the reusable containers and
because the reusable containers are usually much
heavier and more robust than regular containers
i end up having a bigger impact on the
environment than if i just use my normal
products and that's even worse if the product
is so bad i don't end up using it all up
the handy thing about zero co is that they have
hundreds of reviews from customers on their
website everything is overwhelmingly positive
and you can see everyone's experiences with the
products on top of that they sent a lot of their
cleaning products to independent testing labs for
the sorts of comparisons you see from consumer
advocacy groups like choice all of the ones
with published results performed really well for
example you can see their laundry detergent ones
here they also have convenient price comparisons
with supermarket brands on their website
i think sometimes they've chosen their comparisons
very carefully but it isn't like they're comparing
it only to really expensive products obviously
supermarkets have regular sales so it's not like
you're buying everything at full price but i
think a lot of people including me are happy
to pay a little bit more if it's better for
the environment they also have price breakdown
so you can see their pricing structure and
their profit margins which is pretty neat
number three is ingredient transparency
i talked about how i'm allergic to
mi and mci on instagram these are two
preservatives that are commonly found
in detergent and shampoo and about 1.5 percent of
the population is allergic to them unfortunately
a lot of laundry detergents don't list out
their ingredients like a cosmetic product
and they don't even list out their
preservatives like drug products in australia do
i think we hear a lot about how unregulated beauty
products are but we get a lot more information
about them than we do about household products so
i've had a lot of instances where i'll try out a
laundry detergent and then i'll get itchy and
it took me a really long time to narrow it down
to mi and mci i'm still not 100 sure because
it's so hard to track down these ingredients
zero co have ingredients list for all
of their products so it's really easy
to look for allergens i think the only thing
that's missing is the vague "solubiliser" on
the air freshener but you never really see
ingredients list for air fresheners anyway
and they don't really get on your skin
so this is already infinitely great
number four is limited ingredient
fearmongering claims i was actually
expecting the worst from them because
they're from byron bay and that is like the
anti-vax capital of australia this is a super
frustrating topic for me and other scientists
a lot of the time eco-friendliness goes
hand-in-hand with fearmongering claims
about ingredients that make no sense if you
understand the basic principles of toxicology
and that makes me lose confidence in whether
or not they're actually being environmentally
friendly whether or not that is actually based
on science and it isn't just greenwashing
i was pleasantly surprised by the amount
of fearmongering there is a little bit but
it's not too loud and it's near the bottom of the
page so you actually have to scroll to get to it
they have this most insert product name
that you buy from the supermarket contain
harmful chemicals that aren't great for
you your family or the planet which is like
eye roll they do say no nasties but they
don't go deep into the pseudoscience of
how particular ingredients are bad for you
which is nice i'd prefer if they didn't have
this at all but again this is some of the least
fearmongering i've seen from an eco-friendly brand
they do have this cringy moment
where they say no sulfates but
they clearly have sodium coco sulfate
in their hand wash and their body wash
i mean there's nothing wrong with sulfates
but if you're going to make that claim and
fearmonger about sulfates you probably
shouldn't have sulfates in your products
now on to the product reviews i was genuinely
surprised by how much i like the products
i'm used to products from eco brands being
a bit lacking in the performance department
but these were actually really great they smell
really nice they use a lot of essential oils as
their fragrances but it's still quite light
unfortunately there aren't fragrance free
options yet there's only one option for
each product but they're working on that
starting with the laundry liquid this was the
product i was most worried about i'm allergic
to a lot of laundry liquids i've had to change
the sheets in the middle of the night months
because i was itching so much i messaged them
to ask if they recommended their detergent for
people with sensitive skin they said they didn't
know but people with sensitive skin had given
it good reviews so i really appreciated their
honesty there it smells nice it has a light scent
it works well there's no itchiness for me
the forever bottle has the measuring cup lid
and the pouring spout which is standard
in a lot of supermarket brands but not
in all eco brands which i really
appreciate it's really convenient
i'm a bit scared to use their stain remover
because it's one of the few products they
have that have mi and mci the main thing i use
stain removers for is my reusable cotton pads
and i really don't want to get stuff i might
be allergic to in my eyes i did use it once on
cotton pads and it seemed to work pretty well
and i didn't really have any issues with it but
i'm still a little bit cautious my biggest issue
is there's no instructions on the forever bottle
for this so i have to look at the pouch every
time i use it i guess it's fine if you're going
to stick with this for years and years but so far
i haven't used it enough to be familiar with it
the multi-purpose cleaner and
the bathroom and shower cleaner
i don't know what to say about these
they work as well as my other products
they smell okay they still have that sort of
punch you in the nose smell that you get from
regular cleaners it's from the alcohol
which is their main cleaning ingredient
the bathroom cleaner also has lactic acid which
is pretty standard for chlorine-free cleaners
i use the multi-purpose cleaner on most things
i've used it in my plastic bins i've used it on
my induction stovetop and my wooden table and my
stone bench top and i haven't had any trouble with
them it works really well now the air freshener is
the one product that i didn't think i needed like
every other millennial in australia i have the
aesop post poo drops which are essential oils that
you drop into the toilet after you do a poo so i
didn't really think i needed this but i've ended
up really liking it it's a spray air freshener so
it de-stinks the whole room a lot faster you can
also use it in other rooms if someone lets off a
really bad thought this is the other product that
has mi in it so i just try not to breathe it in i
haven't had any issues with it yet it smells nice
i've also been really liking their dishwasher
tablets these are optional they have a starter
kit without the dishwashing tablets
if you don't have a dishwasher they
come in a cardboard box they're little
tablets with the dissolving wrappers
these actually work better than my normal
dishwashing tablets but they are a bit more
expensive in my dishwasher they didn't
leave any droplet marks on my glasses
i did see some people complain about that but
maybe my dishwasher just works particularly
well with these i am a little worried about the
cardboard box because of those dissolving wrappers
moisture can get in really easily maybe would have
been better if it came as like a bottle of powder
the dishwashing liquid is also decent it's not
as good as my normal brand which is morning fresh
i would have preferred this to come with a pump
top but i actually use my pump bottle which i
refill anyway the toilet cleaner also comes in the
same sort of bottle so it's got like a disc lid
i would have preferred a pointy nozzle that
you can aim around the bowl of the toilet
but it actually works pretty decently
the toilet cleaner uses lactic acid
which is pretty common in bathroom
products that are chlorine free
the body wash and the hand wash come in
these pump bottles which is really handy
they smell really nice they have a nice fresh
unisex scent i think it might be a bit strong
for some people again they've said they're
looking into fragrance free versions but right now
these are the only versions available they work
really well they use sulfates sulfates are great
since i bought the box they've
also announced four new personal
care products as well they are a shampoo
a conditioner body lotion and a deodorant
i think this is really convenient because
then those can be shipped with these as well
and getting everything from the one place
is a good way of saving on carbon emissions
again that is assuming these products work
for you if they don't work then it's not
going to be a good system i don't know what the
products are like yet they haven't been launched
unfortunately a few more of these
clean beauty claims have come
in with the personal care products they
claim to be free from silicones sls sles
edta dyes parabens phthalates tea dea
dimethicone formaldehyde and triclosan
it's a bit silly because the shampoo uses sodium
coco sulfate which is the same thing as in the
body wash and the hand wash sodium coco sulfate
is actually about 50% sodium lauryl sulfate sls
lauryl refers to the fatty acid in the surfactant
coconut oil has lauric acid as the main fatty acid
so sodium coco sulfate is actually about
50 sodium lauryl sulfate 16 sodium myristyl
sulfate 10 percent sodium palmitoyl sulfate and
the rest is a bunch of pretty similar sulfates
overall they look like pretty decent
formulas the conditioner doesn't have
silicone so i don't think it's
something i would regularly use
i was actually surprised that they
didn't come out with bar products
maybe it was a bit too hard to formulate
them and put them into their supply chain
another eco brand ethique has byproducts and they
can save a lot on carbon emissions if they work
well one bar is equal to three bottles of shampoo
and it really saves on that weight of the water
that would be there if you had a liquid product
i've tried out a few ethique bars recently and
ethique are one of the least fearmongering eco
brands so check them out if you're interested
unfortunately again their conditioner bar doesn't
work for me because of the lack of silicones
i'm most excited about the deodorant
a lot of people have complained to me
that they want aluminium in their
deodorant so it's antiperspirant
but they can't find one that doesn't have
single-use plastic this is a refillable
roll-on antiperspirant deodorant with
aluminium apparently this is a world
first they have an faq that explains their
decision to use aluminium really nicely
and i wish they did the same for their other
products so they could say something like
fyi we don't use these ingredients but we don't
actually think there's anything wrong with them
the body lotion also looks pretty standard which
is actually a good sign it comes in a pump bottle
so that's an overview of a new
brand i've been trying that i
think is really promising in terms of
how they address being environmentally
friendly and there's a lot less
greenwashing than i usually expect
they still have some gimmicks in there to
hook people in but they've implemented some
pretty solid ideas they also successfully get
around a lot of pain points that i think stop
environmentally friendly brands
from having a larger impact
they're currently only available in australia
i do have a referral link down there
you get 10% off i get 20% off i rarely ever
use brand specific referral links but i do
really like this brand i genuinely think
this is a good idea zero co do have a lot
of discount codes so that might not actually
be the best discount code at time of buying
thanks to jen of the ecowell for helping me
out she is my go-to on sustainable beauty
she has a really great podcast where she
interviews experts and also waste free phd
laura who is great for things about
plastic you can also follow me on instagram
lab muffin beauty science and check out my blog
labmuffin.com for more science behind beauty